welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and definition has officially signed on
for 2021 of the heavy spoilers show
it's pretty crazy news but in addition
to this we also have updates that willem
dafoe will be returning as the green
goblin thomas hayden churches back as
sandman
charlie cox will once more be playing
daredevil and a fantastic fourth theory
that
may end up being how the first family
are brought across to the mcu
you also have a report that the snyder
cut is gonna be r-rated
because batman dropped some f-bombs and
rather than doing two videos i thought
i'd put them all in one but the stories
will be time-coded below if you want to
skip ahead
if this is your first time swinging by
the channel though make sure you smash
that subscribe button
faster than you'd smash aunt may the old
one
and don't forget we're giving away three
free copies of the lord of the rings 4k
box set to our subscribers who leave
comments
but we'll talk about that later in the
video now without the way thank you for
clicking this
let's get into the breakdown okay so
earlier this week i saw something i
shouldn't have
no not that and i've been sitting tight
lipped on it for some time to see if
anyone else reported it before me
luckily i didn't have to wait too long
and quicker than the daily bugle
the illuminati have broke the exclusive
story that both willem dafoe and thomas
hayden church
are in negotiations to reprise their
roles as the green goblin and sandman
during the disney invest today kevin
feige stated that spider-man 3 would be
exploring the multiverse
and over the last couple of weeks we've
had a whole host of announcements
including the return of jamie foxx's
electro
alfred molina as doc ock and andrew
garfield
spider-man now clearly the film has
shaped up to be something special
and though i don't tend to jump on
rumors like this i actually did hear
from quite a reliable source inside
disney
that willem dafoe was who the studio
were really after from the original
trilogy
as he's seen as the most memorable
villain even though he only appeared as
hallucinations sometimes
defoe is the only bad guy to feature in
all three films beside harry
and it's difficult to argue that anyone
is more important in forming peter
parker's journey
well that is still up for debate now you
may remember a while ago that marvel
were actually looking for their own
version of norman osborne
and though it was initially rumored that
christian bale would be taking up the
mantle
we now know that he's playing a far
different character in thor love and
thunder
from what i hear marvel have been pretty
upset with the people that have come
forward
and they're actually looking to bring
dafoe across for the next phase of tom
holland's journey
now i can't say anything beyond dude bro
trust me right now
but hey that's just what i hear and i'm
glad that this report from the
illuminati has came out to kind of back
up what i've been told
according to the report their deals are
being finalized
but they are indeed a part of this
spider-man 3 master plan
unfortunately they were unable to get
any info on the size of their
appearances
however judging by all the cast members
it's hard to imagine them being that
huge and i've also heard tom holland's
gonna be in the filmmaker having that
now when announcements are made this
late into production it normally means
that things are gonna be
a sort of cameo role and that does fit
in with how defoe
may go forth to star in other films and
projects beyond this
the last time we saw osborne he was
being impaled by his own guilder
but a guild gilder gilda
the blade that pierced his body
came from his gilder whilst that was a
death sentence
the fact that we know doc ock is
returning shows that in the multiverse
death
isn't the end and we will likely see a
version appear from an alternate reality
in which he wasn't killed by his own
hand
in the comics this fate befell osborne
but due to the serum within him he was
revived because of a healing factor that
allowed him to be resurrected
so there is president for his return and
for me
this would be the big get in the movie
and though other villains returning like
dark ark are big news
i think that default coming back is the
one that fans are willing to push
and made down the stairs for now so far
the lineup is pretty stacked with with
electro which
i guess yay but this would really teach
sony for killing him off in the first
place
you schmuck you may remember that there
was an original design for the goblins
costume that looked
absolutely incredible and i would love
to see this in live action for the third
mcu outing
the naughties they were a weird time
where it was seen as stupid to make
things look like how they did in the
comic books
but i'm glad that times have changed
because all the leather
though kinky isn't really in keeping
with the characters
the report also states that thomas
hayden church is going to be brought
back due to his power set
being something that will look visually
amazing though i hate sand because
it gets everywhere even in my vagina i
have to admit that the sandman effects
which were used in the third reimi film
really blew my mind at the time and
apparently the studio is going for
things that will look good on screen
which is why they picked to bring him
back alongside electro
yay now he's not the only character
coming back either
and if you're blind then you've probably
missed the news that charlie cox was
returning as their ups
i'm sorry you know what i try to be
clever with the puns but that
that blind one was absolutely atrocious
anyway charlie cox is back as daredevil
for the film
officially now and he will be appearing
as peter parker's lawyer in the movie
before going over to she-hulk for some
fun in this series
now if you cast your mind back to when
your boy was definition all the time
we actually reported on this story and
said that marvel were waiting for the
rights to the character to expire with
netflix
so that things could move over to the
house of mouse and that officially
happened last week before the
announcement
kevin smith also let it slip he'd heard
something in the industry
and though he later denied this it got
widely reported
clearly something had been going on and
actually spoke to the cultured nerd last
week about what was happening
and they said that fergie was planning
on rebooting almost every one of the
defenders
but fan response and the hashtag save
daredevil campaign
completely swayed his mind apparently
what he wanted to do
originally was just reboot the universe
and keep cox and bernathol
aka the punisher but after all the fan
outcry
it made him realize that all these
netflix shows are beloved portrayals
that people want to see in the mcu
now because of this apparently vincent
dinofrio
will also be returning as the kingpin no
one outside of cox is signed on just yet
but with the announcements of several
branches to disney plus that will see
more adult content coming
to the app feige also wants to drop some
big marvel properties on it
that will allow for these characters to
come back bigger brighter
and sassier before give me some sass
now it's all completely mind-blowing
news and it seems that spider-man 3 will
pretty much launch a lot of new mcu
properties
the first three phases of the marvel
universe set up the main timeline which
all built towards endgame but judging
off the upcoming wall crawler movie
the loki trailer doctor strange in one
division
there's gonna be a big focus on the
multiverse going ahead which will allow
for these characters to come across
as well as marvel's first family now if
you watched the disney investor day
event last thursday then you know that
marvel announced they are in the process
of making a fantastic four film
directed by john watts what is behind
the entire spider-man mcu trilogy
and why this is ironic is because the
fantastic four were actually a big
part of spider-man's origins in the
comics so it's like things have almost
been flipped for the film universe
at the moment though we don't have any
casting announcements in regards to it
you've probably seen several rumors over
the last year saying that john krasinski
and emily blunt
have both been in talks to play reed
richards and sue storm respectively
from what i'm hearing this has been
pushed ahead and we should be getting an
official announcement pretty soon
that's probably the rumor out of all of
these that i know the least about
and i'm not too sure on the source but
it's been reported enough by
so many outlets that i think there's a
high possibility it'll come true
now you may remember that in fanfic the
group were messing around with alternate
dimensions
i think that this plot point will be
brought across to the mcu reboot
and it will be how they enter the main
timeline actually think that spider-man
3
may be the first look that we get at
them and it could come in a post-credits
scene that teases their next appearance
as we know marvel liked to set up their
upcoming films through these little
vignettes
so it makes sense for watts to end his
trilogy by showcasing the next franchise
that he's gonna be working on
now before we get into the snyder cut
news don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is make sure you
subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the updates
anyway our last story today revolves
around zack snyder's justice league
and why the director thinks that the
series will be r-rated
in a recent interview with entertainment
weekly home of your weekly entertainment
snyder said the movie is insane and so
epic and is probably rated r
that's one thing i think will happen
that it will be an
r-rated version for sure we haven't
heard from the mpaa
but that's my gut when saying why he
thinks this
he said ben affleck geese is the f word
in one scene
cyborg swears a lot and steppenwolf
hacks hugs people in half
this is pretty big news and it means
that the movie
won't be for kids as batman said
sometimes
you just can't get rid of a bomb but i'm
actually surprised that they're gonna
have the dark knight dropping the f-word
because warner usually tend to market
these things so they can sell toys to
kids
and adults here that that they're not
they're not toys they're action figures
now i think it will completely change
the universe and who knows it might
paint these characters out in a
completely different light going forward
and there has been some backlash to it
and the memes have been
out of this world but meh in the right
context i think it could work quite well
i don't want it to turn into scarface
but you know a couple here and there
probably won't change things too much
now warner bros had no comment in
regards to snyder's statement
so we don't have an official
announcement just yet but with 2021
drawing ever closer it's likely that we
will find out what's happening
sooner rather than later anyway that's
pretty much
all the news and thanks for sticking
with me until the end of the video
the links to our socials are in the
description below and we've also just
created an instagram account
so please get following because because
i'm begging you now if you want
something else to watch
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the marvel what if trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we go through the entire thing and point
out all the easter eggs
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
without the way thank you for visiting
the heavy spoilers show
i've been paul i'll see you next time
yeah you take care of yourself son
peace